hi i'm pablo spechalski and this is
another video in the esc series about
the demo compensation and the bl heli
because you requested me covering this
topic but before we will proceed i would
like to thank all my patreon and youtube
supporters for their backing if you are
not one of them please consider becoming
one and help me create this kind of the
content
but now
let's
go back to the escs
there is
very little information and when i say
very little i do mean very little about
the settings and what they do
when you change them in the bialkali
configurator yes there is this kind of
the public knowledge that okay increase
the timing and increase the demand
compensation
great there is also the official manual
from the bl heli
32 which has like five sentences about
almost everything
and does not really explains too much
and there is what a
post block from philip said by this is
in german and a series of video from
joshua bardwell so
i don't think this is really enough so
let me put my
thoughts and knowledge into the
into the mix and like i mentioned in the
beginning of the video today let's talk
about the dmacc compensation by the way
previously we also talked about the
motor timing the link in the description
and also generally how the esc is really
working and in the future there will be
a few more i only have to shoot those
videos so let's go to the whiteboard the
beer heli dimac compensation
is directly connected towards the
desyncs
and back emf and zero crossing detection
that esc has to perform to rotate the
motor so short introduction i have a
longer video on the topic this one will
be really short
we have a coil one of the coils instead
of the stators and we have the wires
connected to it which are parts of one
of the phases on top of that on the
rotor of the motor
we have a magnet that is just rotating
like that around the coils and esc to be
able to spin the motor correctly it has
to detect
when it should start energizing the coil
so that the coil the phase generates
magnetic fields and pulls the magnet
towards it and to stop doing that this
is called the
zero crossing when the magnet is moving
in this direction right now the coil
should be energized should generate
magnetic field and pull the magnet to
itself but when it comes to this point
it should be released because the magnet
should continue if the coil would not
stop being energized then well it would
pull the magnet this direction and kinda
like break the whole flow so it just has
to know when to start putting the
voltage in the power into the coil and
when to stop doing this this is done
like this is the process like i said
it's zero crossing detection and it's
done thanks to the back emf detection
because not only when the current goes
through the inductor the coil it
generates magnetic fields but on also
moving magnetic fields generates the
voltage the electricity instead inside
of the coil so by observing how the
voltage generated by the magnets
is measured by the esc the esc is able
to predict when the next zero crossing
will happen on which phase and which
phase should be energized in which
time period
but this is a prediction because the
coil should be energized before the zero
crossing happens so esc esc predicts
that the next moment when it should
start will be then or then or then or
then sometimes however esc is wrong
and the reasons why the esc is wrong and
it's putting power through the phases
too early or too late
um
can be different
first of all it's not a perfect process
and even the extra electric noise
somewhere there can just like mess
everything up all that the fact that the
every time you hear inductance and
alternating current you should know that
it's a up situation and
that the current does not follow voltage
is uh it's lagging by 90 degrees and
that means when you even apply the
voltage the current that the magnetic
field will have to slowly grow because
the impedance
sorry inductance is acting as inertia
and when you cut off the voltage also
the current will only slowly go down so
we don't like that we don't like that
but that also means that even if the
the under the energization the process
of generating the magnetic field takes
time and the process of stopping the
magnetic field inside of the coil takes
some time and those imperfections and
just noise electrical
going left and right torques voltage
spikes this all can make esc to fail to
predict the correct moments when it
should
put power through the coil and stop
putting power to the coil when this
happened we usually go into the testing
situation when just the motor stutters
or even stops
in the rotation
usually when you increase the power and
the moment when you increase the power
uh if you if if your esc and the motor
stutters when you immediately increase
the power just because you applied the
throttle on apply the fast
rotation or e3 axis this is where the
demag compensation can help you
not only but this is the most obvious
moment when these dashings are happening
when you
fast
rapidly increase the power demand more
rotation speed from the esc because then
we have acceleration so it's simpler for
the esc just to go nuts
what dima compensation does first of all
it detects the dashing detects that the
the esc might have missed the correct
moment when it doesn't it can do two
things thing number one is to ignore the
current uh
estimation of the rpm of the motor
required to predict when the next
energization of the call should happen
and just
stay with the previous previously
computed value because probably what we
computed right now is just so much of
that trusting the current wrong
situation will even make things
worse so it just stays with the
previously computed rpm and
prediction of the phases and also can
slightly reduce power
this power reduction is driven
by the dmacc compensation setting inside
of the
esc bl heli 32 when it's off then there
is no power reduction uh when it's
low or high then it's either the power
is cut slightly or slightly more but
remember this is only in the situation
but when esc thinks that the dusting is
happening or might be happening in the
future because we are missing the
correct computation uh
correct zero crossing correct
commutation and it just should act what
we get from the lowering of the power on
the coil well
because usually doesn't
are happening during acceleration
we slowly slightly reduce the
acceleration so that we increase the
chances of the previous estimation of
the rpm and zero crossing for the next
phase is correct because we are not
accelerating
by the basically unknown factor we just
try to
keep up with what's happening right now
hoping that slower acceleration will
make the process of estimation more
reliable so this is this is what what
you really should be doing if you are
not facing any kind of the death things
in flight when you just move the
throttle how fast you want and the
motors are just working fine without any
problems no dustings no stutter then
leave the demo compensation how it is by
default don't touch it if however you
are going you're having this moment that
especially on the low kv and the bigger
motors
that you open the throttle rapidly and
some you hear because you even hear that
something wrong is happening then
increase the demag compensation value
the lowering of the power during the
acceleration of the motor will help ex
esc to correctly
predict the correct moments when it
should be
turning off and on
setting low
like i said before limits the power
slightly static high limits power
slightly more it does not mean that the
total power of your motor will be
reduced no esc will make the adjustment
for the power that goes into the coil
only when it will detect d
dashing or future dancing when you are
just rotating or moving this slower and
there is no danger of addressing the
power will not be reduced so you have a
choice um you can have all the power
that you cannot use because when you
apply the full power you go into a
design and the quad falls and some
somehow not really what you want to do
or allow esc to reduce the power during
the acceleration
when the dancing might be happening the
choice is yours i personally rather will
choose the second option when the esc
knows better what's happening and i
prefer to keep the control of the quad
so
fine final
notice if everything is working don't
touch anything if however you are
experiencing death things
increase the demand compensation
slightly from off to low and from low to
high to give esc a better protection
against the decisions caused by the
by the physics because
one of the reasons this is happening is
that when you
turn off the coil it doesn't mean that
the magnetic field is off immediately
because a the voltage is behind current
because there is the inductance and the
phase shift of the current comparing to
the voltage and b this is physics and
see when the magnetic field is there and
then it's interacting with the magnetic
field of the magnet so
physics electrics you can read on the
wikipedia about that i will not bother
you with those kind of problems
i hope this
helps
and that's all about the debug
compensation if you would like to know
more about how esc work and just
basically how the science around the
ursey hobby draws fpv airplanes works
and then i really do suggest that you
subscribe to the channel because the esr
science series is kind of popular right
now and i really do think that it makes
sense to record more and more videos
about that besides that um yeah i think
the regular stuff please consider
becoming my patron on patreon there are
few useful links in the description
there is a link to a
secret but not really secret discord
channel and thank you for watching until
the next one bye
[Music]
you